Speaker 1: We are fortunate that under the
Joe Biden administration, Dr. Anthony Fauci
is not holding back the actual science of
how things work and of medical science, and
we know now that during the Trump administration,
there was a friction that made it to make
it very understated.
We could call it a friction.
It made it so that there was a rift between
the science of coronavirus and the Trump administration's
position on coronavirus.
Since Donald Trump left, we've been hearing
the science from Dr. Fauci and the White House
has simply been on board with that.
And that's a very good thing.
In this vein, Dr. Fauci, yesterday or the
day before responded to comments made earlier
in the week by Fox News host Tucker Carlson,
which we covered, where Tucker suggested that
parents who make their children wear face
coverings are engaging in a form of child
abuse, and that if you see a child wearing
a mask, you should call Child Protective Services
to report child abuse.
The entire rant was delusional by Tucker.
Here's just a little bit of it.
As a reminder, if you
Speaker 2: dare to go on foot from Union Station
to the Capitol, for example, and wash without
wearing a mask, angry Biden voters will snort
at you in judgment.
How could you?
They're saying from behind the cause, how
could you?
That's the question we should be asking of
them in return.
The rest of us should be staring at them first.
They're the aggressors.
It's our job to brush them back and restore
the society we were born in.
So the next time you see someone in a mask
on the sidewalk or on the bike path, do not
hesitate.
Ask politely but firmly.
Would you please take off your mask?
Science shows there is no reason for you to
be wearing it.
Your mask is making me uncomfortable.
We should do that and we should keep doing
it until wearing a mask.
Outside is roughly as socially accepted as
lighting a marble in an elevator.
It's repulsive.
Don't do it around other people.
That's the message we should send because
it's true.
As for forcing children to wear masks outside,
that should be illegal, your response when
you see children wearing masks as they play
should be no different from your response
to seeing someone beat a kid in Wal-Mart.
Call the police immediately, contact Child
Protective Services, keep calling until someone
arrives.
What you're looking at is abuse.
It's child abuse.
And you are morally obligated to attempt to
prevent it.
If it's your own children being abused, then
act accordingly.
Let's say your kid's school emailed you to
announce that every day after lunch, your
sixth grader was going to get punched in the
face by a teacher.
How would you respond to that?
That's precisely how you should respond when
they tell you that your kids have to wear
masks on the soccer field.
That is unacceptable.
It is dangerous.
And we should act like it because it is.
But too few of us have responded like that.
Speaker 1: So Dr. Foushee was asked about
this and he responded in very clear and incredibly
uncertain terms.
Take a listen.
You know, I
Speaker 3: think that's self-evident, that
that's bizarre.
Jim, I don't want to get into a
Speaker 4: back and forth with Tucker Carlson,
but, I mean, it's just almost
Speaker 3: self-evident.
You're talking about child abuse.
Really.
Come on.
Speaker 1: Now, the problem, of course, is
that anybody who believes Tucker to begin
with is not likely to care what Dr. Fauci
says.
I've spoken to many teachers because I have
many friends that are teachers.
And they told me, you know, the last thing
we need right now when we're trying to get
back to teaching is Child Protective Services
being called by Fox News viewers because the
kids are wearing masks.
If we are to think of the kids, that's not
good for the kids.
And then the other thing I've noticed is kids
really don't seem bothered by the masks.
Like, I hate the masks.
I, of course, wear them, but I don't like
wearing a mask.
It's not particularly comfortable now that
they're not required outdoors.
As a vaccinated person, I'm no longer wearing
them outdoors.
But the kids I see with them and friends who
have kids and they talk to me about it, they
all say the kids don't mind it at all.
We seem to find it as adults.
We seem to find the masks more annoying than
the children.
I would actually argue that subjecting children
to Tucker Carlson's rants is way closer to
abuse than simply wearing a mask at school.
And consider the position that Dr. Fauci has
now been in for more than a year.
He is a doctor specializing in immunology
during a global hundred year pandemic.
And he ends up thanks to the Trump administration
and of sycophants like those of Fox News fame.
Dr. Fauci ends up in the position of having
to go on TV to try to disabuse people of the
propaganda that comes from the former administration.
Dr. Fauci, who goes on TV and has to try to
disabuse people of Tucker Carlson, is nonsense
disinformation.
Remember that Fox News lawyers stated during
a defense of Tucker Carlson in a legal complaint,
quote, No reasonable person would take Tucker
Carlson literally.
It is entertainment.
It is not news.
He uses hyperbole.
He uses exaggeration.
And it's quite similar to the Alex Jones defense
of you can't go after Alex Jones for things
that he says on his show because he is essentially
playing a character on his show.
And certainly no one should take it seriously,
Jones or Tucker Carlson.
But there are a lot of unreasonable people
who watch Tucker and do believe it's a news
show.
Now, my last thought on this merely as a curiosity,
as a thought experiment.
What would happen if someone called Child
Protective Services or even 911 one and said,
I'm calling to report that children are being
forced to wear masks?
Does anyone show up in certain situations?
Police have to show up.
If you call with a certain complaint and then
say, sorry, cancel it.
There are certain types of things where police
have to just go and check things out.
If you call and say children are wearing masks,
would anyone even listen to you?
Or is Tucker's suggestion, if followed, just
destined to be ignored by Child Protective
Services?
Now, the other strange thing about the anti
massacres is that many of them believe covid
is a lab made bioweapon from China.
If you really believed that covid was a bioengineered
bioweapon from China, why the hell wouldn't
you be wearing a mask?
That, again, is an example of where a lot
of these anti science beliefs conflict when
you put two of them together.
Needless to say, hopefully not that much longer
that Dr. Fauci will need to be on TV refuting
this nonsense.
Maybe that's that's optimistic thinking.
I
don't know.
Hey,